[Music]
near autumn Mata released something
fittingly weird for this game you can
fight the square Enix CEO yossi came up
Yosuke Matsuda and the platinum CEO
kenichi Sato you can fight them as
bosses in this DLC so this prompted the
question what are some of the weirdest
DLC packs we've ever played cuz there
have been some odd ones are we going to
show some of the okay here we go really
it's an actual fight of it because i
watched it this morning in that is a
square or that's a square enix CEO that
is so thick euless oh he just told me so
like they fight with a mix of just like
hanahan martial arts but they also can
emit like clouds or drones that are just
their heads which you can see mine
that's what we need alright but have you
guys played much of this game but
because i know that it's said time and
time again that despite the slew of
Awesome releases this year this game is
fantastic i played i just telling rob
before the show I've been playing a lot
more of it like between persona five
bouts this game is really really good
and all the weird [ __ ] in it just feels
so right for this game yo guitar oh he's
done other stuff like that he did um
drakengard reckon guard yeah it's like
his style but I don't know I I don't
know if I'll get the time to play this
dlc yet but they have level 85 give me a
sound tie but platinum CEO and president
like he's just motion I Chicago send
from the sky yeah that's awesome oh you
think time your breathe yeah yeah if you
if we stick with this the fight looks
like super just chaotic and the player
ultimately dies in this clip stop trying
to hit me and hit me yeah you end up
some guy was watching the matrix on a
flight the other day and it got stuck in
my head you think that's a game you're
playing many watch matrix reloaded and
then I fell asleep oh yeah I stopped
using my spare time playing this to try
to play more persona and I'm feeling
like not that that's a mistake but maybe
I want a shelf persona for now mmm go
back to this can i yeah I'm kind of
having that same debate I just there's a
lot of games the beginning of this year
that are going to take up a lot of time
to play like right I'm still playing
zelda and I
I'm trying to finish that so I can move
on basically but i'm not sure if I want
to move on to persona or to this and I
kind of want to move on to this looking
at this battle because I want to fight a
CEOs head is this game game like this is
seems like every stick like an arena
duck dungeon yeah I mean judging by how
the rest of the game is structured it
might be something you travel to in the
open world but yeah like you said it
just seems pretty basic Coliseum kind of
thing but yeah this is one of those
games that uh I mean do pariah in the
twitch chat was just saying it needs to
be in a game of the air discussion I
totally I mean I know it's only what is
it April I know it's only April but this
is definitely where those games that I
don't want to let get overshadowed by
all the other very fantastic games
coming out this year but I think there's
any question it's one of the best out of
the third of the year that's passed yeah
it's great for platinum because they've
kind of had a rough between we talk
about this all the time scale beyond
being cancelled on xbox one and also the
last release i think was TMNT turtles in
manhattan mutants in manhattan I always
forget the name but I didn't play it
anyway yeah so we wanted to talk about
other weird DLCs we've played throughout
the years because there are there's
quite the plethora of them the first one
I want to talk about and it's quite
popular undead nightmare for red dead
redemption essentially did you guys play
this no no okay yeah well it essentially
just kind of reskin red dead redemption
and put zombie Zhaan it back in the
middle of the zombies hey day after like
left 4 dead and dead rising were huge I
liked it it was it was self-referential
a decision it I think this is the
Bigfoot Bigfoot I'm okay with this yeah
I I feel like that's my spirit animal
right there I feel like that's you yeah
that's yeah that's your Patronus yeah
that's the signature you're on the right
yeah well i'm john marston with a
six-shooter I'm just a silent hairy man
sitting against a tree ah so head kill
me anyway zombies like one of the more
like some of the more out of some of the
bigger DLCs undead nightmare actually
kind of went back to reskin much of red
dead redemption in place undead in this
world and kind of told this story I
forget what the actual justification was
for it but it was a man
you think I don't exist how are you so
sure you exist I'm here maybe were all
Bigfoot on the inside what is he saying
such a mano yeah I'm that nightmare when
that nightmare is probably a good one to
get into another one with his enter the
dominatrix that was that clip showed
nothing of undead nightmare but just
Majesty romantic comedies in my
definition that's undead nightmare oh
here we go John Lucas he's back at it I
enter the dominatrix was originally
teased in April of 2012 as a april
fool's joke dlc for Saints Row 3 was
never finished and then it ended up
being released as DLC for saints row 4
and I didn't really realize how weird it
was until I finally played it like two
years ago I think it release it must've
been yeah yeah get it very very sex
tinged but there are these cutscenes
it's very self referential they talk
about it's kind of a parody into what
it's like to make a game or how games
change along the way because there are
these live action cut scenes of
developers from volition acting out the
scenes feel that they didn't have time
to finish but they kind of like stuff
like this yeah they don't they get into
like how it was it started as an April
Fool joking that people wanted it so
they fit into saints row so they just
yeah I kind of want to play this it is
it's very good it's kind of a cool like
I said it's it's all seats 80 racal
about maybe not DLC but just how games
are made and it's really funny yeah it's
breaks the fourth wall every which way
and it also calls itself out when it is
not in like canon or when it breaks
congruent with the main game it's like a
parallel story line it's really good I
like super want to go back to saints row
for now just my phone it is that's like
it in the vein of Just Cause kind of
that dumb open-world fun in Saints Row
your Saint row foyer actually like a
superhero that whole series evolved so
weird the first one was kind of more
grounded gritty like almost like you
know chasing it for the GTA vibe but
then for they just develop their own
weird crazy identity and enter the
dominatrix seems to be
tens yes volition now is working on
agents of mayhem which has the same
flavor from that's my Patricia boys
getting married this guy I'll just say
where's the other Raptor go oh no that's
me yeah okay uh that was entered
dominatrix more recently I want to talk
about res evil 7 sdlc they've been
pretty been releasing a lot of TLC like
right after it came out which I think
served it well had a long tail as far as
beating those huge release but here's
birthday party that's weird on 20
[ __ ] weird Jack Baker and he it's
this is the more comical and John Luke I
know played through the whole thing but
based on the other DLC that played for
this game I didn't get the chance play
birthday party but it did look super
weird I think John Luke and Joey
streamed it at some point and even the
enemies yes he's got like Confed it's
like grunt birthday party for me but
it's got all the molded enemies have
birthday hats on so if you're scared of
this game this is probably the way to
play all right I guess so but I don't
know this scares me more I was gonna say
this is pretty creepy clowns oh this
totally breaks the like horror vibes no
this approves me out more why more oh it
does not say I am I am upset who paid
you to say that liars kept coming
there's someone behind a camera here no
but yeah outside of it got full vote on
outside of the birthday for a DLC
terrific you should definitely if you
are a fan of res evil 7 play the dlc
they've released there's a lot of cool
stuff to do those the escape rooms with
Lucas and they kind of you know you can
go back through madhouse difficulty play
in VR this game is fantastic also game
of your contender in my mind even though
it's only April but a pepper grinder I
want to talk about okay I'm not scared
anymore good XCOM 2 very minor one
compared to these but an turkeys
children um this is just another excuse
for me to talk about XCOM 2 because i'm
gonna say [ __ ] love this game I was
playing this yesterday Rob you kind of
saw meme you might have but uh it it
takes the idea of what if humans didn't
become this just rebellion when the
aliens took over and if they became this
like punk the purge is the dumbest movie
that's coming to mind right now about
the aesthetic with these Mohawks I don't
know just this post-apocalyptic
I mean for lack of a better term can't
see anarchy and you can have these Sam
the lower face mask part you can have
these samurai like muzzles it's pretty
badass but it also gets weird in the
sense that some of the outfits are like
these [ __ ] costume is kind of like these
tight leather thing that one's sick I'd
wear that in real life uh-huh um there's
a lot of mods for this game so DLC is
kind of hard to recommend an ex-con to
because there's so many mods that are
free that you can just play and people
have implemented stuff like this but an
turkeys children was cool because it
kind of lent a lot more color to your
team rather than these just militaristic
looking outfits throughout the whole
thing uh yes so moving on to another one
that wasn't exactly DLC but a spawn for
another game is far cry 3 blood dragon
sorry far cry blood dragon after far cry
3 this weird project developed became
this 80s um I didn't know how you would
describe it 80s like outrun kind of
cyberpunk II not even cyberpunk it just
took like a tease action movies and made
it into a far cry like a bite-sized like
Tron yes without run music and [ __ ] it
was really fun and we're still
capitalizing on 80s nostalgia I feel
like with a lot of games releases but
this seemed to kick that off maybe you
end up getting a power glove later on
you punch this reactor to destroy the
base it's really fun but it's really
cool that it developed like that i think
it's like takes 12 hours as opposed to
far cry 3 which took more of a i don't
know 50 our approach I just like that it
completely changes the themes like it's
just a complete switch yeah I love a
tease I love 80 [ __ ] so I was like all
about this yeah it was kind of you know
looking back it's cool that Ubisoft
greenlit this no that was pretty sick
but yeah play this if you haven't it's
standalone on xbox 360 ps3 it's worth
playing cool and then I just also wanted
to touch more on call to be zombies we
were talking about before the show today
um you know as good as most called 2d
games are at least okay zombies is
always really interesting it was just
treyarch but then with a infinite
warfare as infinity ward's first time
doing as opposed to some other like wave
based mode but Rob and I were talking I
forget how many maps their offers on
just like 22 or something 23 with a
franchise
Hans yeah there's like a continuity with
like the with black ops zombies and
there's it's like there's a whole it's a
whole thing yeah there's no deep
original four characters there's a
Japanese character a German character
and two Americans what that started a
Russian Russian and Russian oh uh it's
not res no its residents later but yeah
I was kind of the people that were in
the factions that were included in like
the first call of duty world at war and
then they ended up they becoming the
first one was I think just nacht der
untoten night of the undead mm-hmm you
seem to know German more than I do based
on the conversation this morning it's
290 yeah and then you know like derives
came along that was my favorite yeah
that was where I was telling you guys
when my buddy and I would play till like
3am it's like do we have class tomorrow
we'd pause it wave 28 and then go to bed
and try to pick up where we left off and
we were just so naive are you ready ok
I'm pause dad cuz you just you develop
such a momentum and a rhythm that you
you can't just sleep on it and pick it
back up at the game is just intense um I
would stay up with my brother and play
yeah just their fun yeah I think uh so
what was the previous one block black
ops 3 right black ops 3 had like the
sort of like wah wah this is ardee with
the noir one Jeff Goldblum was in it
they started getting super weird with
celebrity appearances here is a danny
trejo Johnny Danny Trejo sarah michelle
gellar but they actually started
bringing celebrities into it but that
didn't it didn't at any point feel like
a gimmick because they were just I mean
it's I guess it could but they they're
all quality but here's the kind of shi
no numa zombie swamp from the first
black or sorry world at war where it
started this is always a treyarch thing
and then with Infinity Ward or with
infinite warfare Infinity Ward took a
swing in it and they were look at their
own spin on it because it's like 80 same
zombies in space land is super fun and
they're really cheeky I really like
zombies in face land yeah and for those
of you watching this live like I said
there'd be a live stream later at two
p.m. pacific Scott Butterworth and Joey
from gamespot will be hosting and
playing with developers from infinity
ward that worked on zombies for infinite
warfare anyway yeah
snow if we didn't mention a DLCs that
you wanted to hear talked about let's no
twitch at YouTube chat hit us up on
Twitter comment on this if you're
watching on YouTube after the fact
[Music]